Harry we've said at this point that the
order of axe sounds a little bit like
the way in which Paul rides
and now we have Paul coming to Corinth
and arriving there and when he gets
there there's kind of an interesting
moment when he deals with the Jews we
talked about the way in which he seems
to start up with a synagogue in verses
five following and then sounds harsher
than he has anywhere along the way
trying to his response to the Jewish
people you want to help us understand
that a little bit yeah we've talked a
little bit about this before the way in
which in which Luke sets up Paul's
missionary activity always preaching to
the Jews first and then going to the
Gentiles and he has the same pattern
here and acts 18 for every Sabbath he
would argue in the synagogue and try to
convince Jews and Greeks but as usual he
doesn't have much success with a Jewish
audience and in acts 18:6 when they
opposed and reviled him and protest he
shook the dust from his clothes which is
something that Jesus advised his
disciples to do with a missionary first
course and interacted like yeah and said
there was the dust from the feet but
that's the aleutian same idea right and
and he said your blood be on your own
heads I am innocent from now on I will
go to the Gentiles yeah that's a little
harsh
it reminds us a little bit of that that
blood libel in Matthew's Gospel where
the crowds in Jerusalem say his blood be
on our children which I think in Matthew
is a kind of precursor to the
destruction of Jerusalem and hydrogen of
Deuteronomic theology but it's been
certainly misused and hugely in the
history of the West yeah and this verse
I think is is of a piece with that it's
we'll see the the polemical elements the
jabs at the Jews getting a little more
intense in some of these letters and so
I think it's part of that that program
of Luke to make some sort of
differentiation between his community
and the Jews that don't accept yeah and
when we get to the very end in 28 I'm
going to want to ask you again about how
that how that stands at the end of the
story I will we know is it now always
like that yes they're all rejection or
there's some hope in this same chapter
of chapter 18 there's reference to
Gallio as the proconsul of akia and i
member for my prelim exams years and
years ago the Gallio is one of the few
characters in these stories about it we
have a fair amount of secular evidence
we know about Gallio not just in
Scripture but outside of Scripture and I
think that's helped us on our dating of
when Paul was doing what is that right
right the the theory here is that we can
pin down within a year or two the time
when Gallio was in office in Corinth
knowing what we know about the terms of
Roman governorships of Pro consulates
and we have an inscription that mentions
Gallio and that can be dated fairly
precisely because it refers to an event
in in Roman Imperial history the
proclamation of the unit was a
celebration of the Emperor and a factor
X number of times yeah and we know when
that happened and so we can date
gallio's term - 51 52 of the Common Era
so sometime during that period if Luke's
memory is corrected it seems to be in
this section of acts that he's grounds
for some sort of historical
documentation if Paul had some sort of
encounter with Gallio than he was in
Corinth in the early 50s 51 52 somewhere
so although we can't pin it down
precisely to the month that some people
try a good general idea of when this
episode took place okay and that enables
us to give give a kind of chronological
framework to Paul's correspondence he
would have written to the Corinthian
community after this time and probably
to the Galatian community during the
time that he was writing to the Congress
okay and to the Roman community
absolutely so between the period
referred to here in acts 18 and Paul's
trip to Jerusalem is probably about a
six five to six or span maybe seven
years span all in the mid-50s yeah so it
does give us a peg on which to hang Paul
on chronology totally unrelated to the
direct topic for the day but it often
strikes me in discussions of Paul on
theology we try to show how it developed
over the years but it was
that many years no this is this is a
fairly short window of time in which
he's writing all these letters certainly
all the letters that everybody agrees we
have that right the undisputed letters
right the letters that are a little bit
if he might have but some of them might
have been written later and you had have
been written from Rome yeah yeah I've
decade or so yeah tell us a little about
a palace and about Prisca and de cuello
who are characters both here and
elsewhere in Paul's story right so in
the end of chapter 18 we have in Ephesus
an encounter with the Jew named Apollo's
as Luke tells it a native of Alexandria
an eloquent man well versed in the
scriptures so someone in some ways a
little like Luke it would say yeah
someone who has a good Greek education
and has a way of interpreting that the
biblical text we know of Apollo's from
Paul's letters he was a missionary and
worked the Corinthian scene yeah he had
been there according to the opening
chapters of 1st Corinthians and he was
apparently with Paul in Ephesus when
Paul wrote a letter the letter and sends
his greetings and I always suspect
slightly more eloquent than Paul
probably probably quite defensive knows
when he gets to this first Corinthians
Paul was a little bit touchy but here
Apollo's is put in his place as being
someone who came into this movement kind
of through the back door knowing all of
the baptism of John Luke tells us and so
these other missionaries Prisco a
priscilla and aquila had to instruct him
about the full form of baptism and get
him fully aboard which he did and he was
then powerfully refuting the jews in
public showing that jesus is the messiah
so Chris Keller Quiller are also people
that we know from Paul's correspondence
and places like at the end of Romans
okay that they are companions of his
maybe even relatives of his and it's not
quite clear who was the leading
character in this husband-and-wife team
might well be Priscilla might well be
that was they the chief missionary
activist hero so yeah these are all
people that we know of from Paul's
correspondence
as members of his circle people that he
knew in the missionary world
Apollo's also pops up in some later
speculation as a candidate for the
author of the Epistle to the Hebrews
Martin Luther thought that that was the
solution today at the anonymous that
anonymous text so we'll ponder this
another day together okay that'll be
great and I think it also reminds us how
mobile Christian people are certainly
Christian people in a certain economic
class because priscilla and aquila
appear here and then they appear there
and it seems that the god paul is not
the only one traveling around in these
days right of course with priscilla and
aquila the story is that they were cast
out of rome at the time of the expulsion
of Jews from under Claudius which
probably took place in the late 40s or
some people data earlier but the general
consensus around 4849 so and that might
have something to do with the situation
in Rome that Paul was addressing in in
Romans but in any case they would have
been business people who had some sort
of trade and worked out of Rome probably
in the import-export business and so it
wasn't hard for them to pick up their
their business activities in the Aegean
area yeah good and we've already said a
couple words about John's baptism and
the baptism of the holy spirit just want
to reiterate that one scenes for
repentance and one seems for what
giftedness yeah it's it's clear from
this episode at least that at this point
Luke seems to be suggesting that that
the full baptism is how to get when you
get it with the Holy Spirit and it's not
simply about repenting else about
empowerment and it's the kind of thing
that is supposed to make you into a
person the like of which one encounters
at Pentecost we have once again in
chapter 19 the the sense in which there
is some kind of opposition to Paul again
if we remember with a slave girl kind of
mercenary motives when we have the the
crying out about the riot and Ephesus
and the claim that somehow he's
destroying the idolatrous works that
make life so happy for them what's going
on there in terms of Luke's
larger context given how do you yeah
well there are a couple of thousand
episodes where rivals appeared before
that we have the excuse story of the
sons of Skiba supposedly a Jewish high
priest what Jewish high priest is doing
in Ephesus in history with magical sons
yeah and they said these kids are out
doing exorcisms in the name of Jesus and
they get shown up because the demons
won't respond to them yeah they're
misusing the name of Jesus I think this
is another one of these semi comic
episodes we've seen several of them in
in acts and so seeing these rival EXO 6
hoisted on their own petard his way of
poking fun at some of the rivals of
early Christianity you think what we get
sometimes in the end the Gospels do with
the false prophets and false messiahs a
kind of misuse of the name of Jesus from
Luke's perspective that that the name is
out there and people use it for right
cause and for wrong cause right there
there's at least one other episode in
acts where someone seems to want to use
the powers of Christianity or his own
purposes this is a Simon back in Samaria
wants to buy the Apostles power to to
heal and to and alike yeah by giving us
the name simony right so these these
sons of sceva
are the same ilk but getting to the
right in ephesus yeah we have this is a
long episode this was quite long I mean
it's almost the fully half of yes this
chapter chapter 19 and it has it says
somewhat comic dimensions to mean it
this serious issue here that the the
Christian movement was undermining
traditional observances of a sort or
another and we know of that from the
correspondence between plenty and Trajan
that right both in iya there was a
similar sort of problem in the early
part of the second century temples were
being neglected and traditional rights
were being ignored or this new heresy
yeah and so Luke seems to be sensitive
to that and says well what Paul was
doing there at Ephesus was the kind of
thing that would have resulted in this
kind of reaction even if a lot of this
might be his his
it ends kind of in a curious way an
unnamed town clerk quiets the crowds
that have gathered in the Animas
theatres of Ephesus so the story kind of
lacks verisimilitude but it it shows the
victory over Artemis the overturning of
traditional cult that's part of the the
way in which the world is being upended
remember that theme absolutely no
absolutely
our friend Eutychus just a quick word on
that a little bit like Ananias and
Sapphira it's a great story right and
here I think we see Luke doing a little
bit of literary borrowing okay because
the episode here sounds an awful lot
like something that we find in Homer's
Odyssey mmm-hmm
when Odysseus goes to the underworld he
encounters a fellow named LP noir who
had died after falling out of window
after drinking too much and at a dinner
with Odysseus and his friends and he has
a famous line wide in the unspeakable
fate of the gods has destroyed me and so
this there's a very close proofing and
the fate of the gods is destroyed for
you that's right in history you wonder
if Luke is getting it perhaps that yeah
yeah exactly
drilled on I've often thought that a
kind of I hope a helpful link between
Paul's world
Luke's world in the world just after
Luke is there in that speech to the
Ephesian elders that my leaders and let
me just put out my theory and see what
you think that this is this is a place
where Luke begins to tell us alright
what's now for the next generation how
does our church and the Church of our
children carry on this tradition that we
saw start with the Apostles move to Paul
who are you supposed to be now leaders
of this church does that make any sense
oh I think it does yeah now we've
already spoken a little bit about this
when we were talking about the Apostles
and the Deacons way back when that is
that this one way in which Luke is
telling the story that reflects the
realities of his own time and I think by
having the the elders of the presbyters
they Ephesian community come to him he's
reflecting what we know from some other
sources
the general authority structure of the
church - at the end of the first century
where local communities tend to be
governed by groups of elders and
assisted by details right yeah yeah we
see that in Rome we sittin in Asia Minor
and it also tends to reflect the kind of
understanding of church order that we
find they the pastoral versus oh yeah
that there are some good connections
here some people even think that the
author of Acts was the author of they
the pastoral yeah we don't have Jerome
Quinn bought that we don't but there you
can see a line I think it kind of
continuities so the church in Ephesus
that comes to meet Paul it might it's
not a versus reflects I think the Church
of looks like oh yeah that's right the
other thing about the content of this
speech unlike the missionary speeches
that we've seen both from the mouth of
Peter mouth of Paul which begin from
Scripture and try to say something about
the significance of Christ his death and
exaltation and repentance and acceptance
of the the mission of forgiveness that's
coming through the gospel this this is
not an evangelistic speech it's a speech
that looks forward yeah and it's a kind
of a warning speech yeah it says that
they were you know going to be savage
wolves that will not spare the flock so
I think Luke here is reflecting the the
element of controversy that develops
within early Christianity by his day
right when people are debating things
like exactly what we mean by calling God
Jesus yeah yeah yeah saying saying he's
incarnate what is that really only in
fear yeah so there were controversies
that we are brewing at the end of the
first beginning of the second century as
well as they the controversies that
we've already alluded to in some past
conversations about how much Jewish
observance needs to be reserved in the
right the Christian community so this
speech is in some ways a prophecy before
the event yes after yeah looking good on
the lips
or some of these kind of mercy stairways
and I think says don't you that the that
this tradition of who Jesus is and who
the church is that are learning from be
Luke is the one passed down from Paul it
has now passed down to the next
generation your if you if you elders are
faithful to what you're learning this
book you'll be faithful against the
wolves yeah I think that's true there's
another interesting dimension to this
speech and this is a reminiscence of
some things in Paul's own writing when
he offers a apologies for his own
apostolic activity so in acts 20:32 and
following 33 I coveted no one's silver
or old or clothe they are that you know
for yourselves that I work with my own
hands to support my selves and my
companions this is precisely the sort of
thing that Paul says in first
Corinthians now also in second
Corinthians so we we hear some authentic
reminiscences of Paul's own apology for
himself in various letters and I think
an authentic and timeless warning about
making too much money from spreading the
gospel yeah that's right from that day
until now yeah and finally it is more
blessed to give them to receive finally
it was a proverbial wisdom at the end of
it thank you